[Musique]
tu fous là je suis jeune en bonne santé
pas une raison pour squatter mon frigo
je n'ai donc pas de raison de me
vacciner hockey
du beurre c'est du président
défunt ah oui mais elle est bonne vous
faire vacciner faites le pour les autres
quel autre vos parts les connaissances
vos grands parents tous marre de vos
amis ce n'est pas cela arrive et ouais
on va pas jusqu'à dire autre chose
ça à faire nourrir
[Musique]
ses clés
la fête des mères
le clitoris
[Musique]
un enfant c'est plus beau des cadeaux
congélateur c'est pas mal comme cadeau
aussi
[Musique]
jours
bon
[Musique]
avec deux matches
annie thani j'ai une personne qui
arrêtent pas de battre les souvent
numéro c'est toujours la même chose et
puis quand je serai pas me dit était
trop beau j'ai envie d'être avec toi je
suis je regarde les fainéants j'étais
numéro avec mathison sens et une voisine
à clara
est
[Musique]
méritée gars du pq en d'asseoir vérifier
quelles astuces au parent avant
d'allumer l'ordinateur
effacer l'historique
[Musique]